- [Instructor] Pamela was asked to find
where h of x equals x to the third
minus six x squared plus 12
x has a relative extremum.
This is her solution.
So step one, it looks like she
tried to take the derivative.
Step two, she tries to find the solution,
find where the derivative is equal to zero
and she found that it
happens at x equals two
so she says that's a critical point.
In step three, she says,
she makes the conclusion
that therefore h has a
relative extremum there.
Is Pamela's work correct?
If not, what's her mistake?
So pause this video and try
to work through it yourself
and see if Pamela's work is correct.
Alright, well, I'm just gonna try
to do it again in parallel.
So first, let me just
take the derivative here.
So h prime of x.
Just use the power rule multiple times.
It's gonna be three x squared
for the x to the third.
Two times negative six is
negative 12 or minus 12 x
and then the derivative of 12
x is plus 12 and let's see.
You can factor out a three here.
So it's three times x squared
minus four x plus four
and this part is indeed
equal to x minus two squared.
So this is equal to three
times x minus two squared.
So her step one looks right on target.
Okay, step two, the
solution of h prime of x
is equal to zero is equal to x equals two.
Yeah, that works out.
If you were to say,
if you were to say three
times x minus two squared
which is h prime of x,
the first derivative,
and set that equal to zero,
this is going to be true
when x is equal to two
and so any point where
your first derivative
is equal to zero or it's undefined,
it is indeed a critical point.
So this step looks good so far
and then step three, h
has a relative extremum
at x equals two.
Alright, so she made
a big conclusion here.
She assumed that because
the derivative was zero,
that we have a relative extremum.
So let's just see if you can
even just make that conclusion.
In order to have a relative extremum,
your curve is gonna
look something like this
and then you would have a
relative extremum right over here
and over here, your slope
goes from being positive
and then it hits zero and
then it goes to being negative
or you could have a
relative extremum like this.
This would be a maximum point.
This would be a minimum
point right over here
and then in a minimum point,
your slope is zero right over there
but right before it,
your slope was negative
and it goes to being positive
but you actually have cases
where your derivative,
your first derivative is zero
but you don't have an extremum.
So for example, you could
have a point like this
where right over here,
your slope or your derivative
could be equal to zero
and so your first derivative
would be equal to zero
but notice, your slope
is positive, it hits zero
and then it goes back
to being positive again
and so you can't make the conclusion
just because your derivative is zero
that it's definitely an extremum.
You could say it's a critical point
and so step two is correct.
In order to make this conclusion,
you would have to test what
the derivative is doing
before that point and after that point
and verify that it is switching sides
and we could try to do that.
So let's make a little table here.
Make a little table.
Do it a little bit neater.
So x, x, h prime of x right over here.
We know at x equals two,
h prime of two is zero.
That's our critical point.
But let's try, I don't know,
let's see what happens
when x is equal to one
and then let's see what
happens when x equals three.
I'm just sampling points
on either side of two
and let's see, we are going to have,
when x is equal to one,
h prime of one is three
times one minus two squared.
One minus two, negative
one squared is positive one
times three is still
positive and then three.
Well, three minus two squared times three.
That's also gonna be three.
So this is actually a situation where,
like I've just drawn it
where our slope is positive
before we hit the critical point,
it gets to zero but then it
starts becoming positive again
and so that's why you
actually have to do this test
in order to identify
whether it's an extremum.
It turns out that this is not an extremum.
This is not a maximum
or a minimum point here.
So Pamela's work is not correct
and her mistake is step three.
In order to make this conclusion,
you would have to test on either side
of that critical point.
Test the first derivative.